I was [ __ ] off the baron-cohen
for those you guys don't know Sasha
Baron Cohen is he's Borat he's Bruno
he's Ali G he's a legend yo okay so and
the clip that we're referencing he
basically you want you have to clear
yeah I guess so it's not gonna be uh he
went to it not an all right rally but he
went to a group that was like a militia
group in Washington State and got on
stage somehow and started singing this
wild-ass song as a country singer like
he put on makeup and all the [ __ ] and
then some people started singing along
and I don't remember the exact lyrics
but something about like giving him give
him Obama of the Wu Han flu and cut off
the journalists head like the Saudis do
or something much like the Saudis do
yeah
Wuhan flu like is only stills from it on
to you now there's a video but it's all
guys it chopped them up like the Saudis
do yeah yeah um thoughts Akash so here's
the one thing that's a bit unfair as I
like research it a little more it wasn't
it says white supremacist rally in the
article these guys are actually very
anti racism there like a militia group
that's like we believe in guns and all
that but we're not doing this we're not
doing racist [ __ ] and then apparently
once like a few people started singing
along they were like you'll get the [ __ ]
out of here and Sasha showed up with
like a ton of security and [ __ ] yeah I
mean it's also I mean these are a group
of people that believes in guns you're
gonna say some [ __ ] to piss them off
right to their face what you're saying
calling them white supremacists
it's a bit unfair I mean like he needed
to get it done and whatever and like I'm
not including when they kicked him off
for saying it yeah yeah so I thought it
was an unfair bit of marketing yeah um
but here's that usually what he does so
that's the thing with him like I [ __ ]
die laughing at some in some of the
hardest I've ever laughed is at some of
like the Olly G stuff or like the Bruno
or at Borat stuff I mean like [ __ ]
die laughing that being said it is the
easiest type of humor like he literally
does like the most juvenile low-hanging
fruit type of humor that exists he
basically finds the ostracized
people like whoever the leading group or
the elites are of that country right he
finds the group that they hate and
ostracize and then confirms their bias
based on the stereotypes they have so in
America obviously the leading group are
like you know lefties and they run
Hollywood etc so he goes okay who do
they hate oh they hate these like
rednecks so I'm gonna go find white
people being racists and then confirm
that they're racist right so I'll go to
this Trump rally or I'll do another
thing etc it's like first of all you're
some [ __ ] spoiled brat that went to
Oxford you don't know dick about America
right like you don't know anything about
people in the south at all all you knew
was okay I can make money if I come here
and confirm how those rich white people
feel about those poor white people so
that's well do Oh
what do Americans hate right now oh they
hate Muslims because they're in a war
with Muslims okay I'll make a movie
where I make Muslims look really bad The
Dictator right it's like I don't see him
keeping that same energy you know with
anything like I don't see I don't see
him coming after Jews at all he's a
Jewish guy he just points out like white
racism and anti-semitism I think that's
what he's pointed out I was even looking
for characters I was I guess interesting
like has he ever done a like a character
shows like Israel Palestine relations oh
it is who is America show yeah I
remember being excited about it did he
go at left-wing people though cuz the
clips that went viral world I mean there
were wild like getting [ __ ] senators
to say some crazy [ __ ] and do some super
gay [ __ ] or whatever but like there was
one character he did in that who's
America show I think was Aaron Murad
where he plays like an Israeli anti
terrorist yeah I teaching like people at
a corporate offers how to like deal with
terrorists I'm [ __ ] dying laughing
it's hilarious i me as the guy dressed
up as an Indian and then have a snake
charm and that's how you I die laughing
at it it's stupid it's but it is super
like juvenile but it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's just so stupid that being said like
I don't know if he's keeping the same
energy seems a little bully ish it's
bulliest and you don't know anything
about the culture you're some [ __ ]
snob from English
you're some rich boy from England and
you frontin so you can make money off of
this stereotypes that these elites that
these elites have that's all you and I
got caught up in it because I was this
New York elite you know putting quotes
on that but like I was one of these
homes your guys postal guys that knew
nothing about the south before I really
start to learn about these people right
and like have family from there so I
could really understand their
perspective but like before I was like
oh yeah look how races they are ha ha ha
I have these feelings and then I'll go I
don't even know if Yuri watch Borat
though it's just like some funny-ass
antics like the second he gets to New
York and he lets the [ __ ] she opens
up his briefcase and a [ __ ] chicken
comes out and starts running around like
he goes to feminist groups and like
picks it down like he does go at
everybody but he tends to pick on the
rednecks I don't think he goes at
everybody I think he goes at why people
are racist I think those white people
are racist I think that's it I think we
know that and I don't think we need some
guy from England coming here to tell us
that but it seems like that's what a lot
that that's my I laugh on a primal level
and I die laughing again promote from a
laughing perspective I'm [ __ ] crying
yeah like that's the end of the goal and
that's at the end of it that's what
matters that's what matters
a hundred percent yeah what I value
about us is we're coming to everybody
everybody gets let's go we're coming
Muslims and we'll come and juice will
come at black food will come a white
people coming in it's everybody gets
these jokes his jokes have a specific
target yeah a specific audience and he's
not keeping that same energy not even
with himself he's Jewish I'm sure
there'd be a million jokes he could make
about himself his culture his people go
out to his seeds he could go with his
seeds but he's not it's all abusers
gonna go on Muslims and why you gonna go
on Muslims and you're gonna go ahead
white white racist like really that's it
is there something where it's like he's
making fun of Muslims but in such an
exaggerated way that it's like nobody
actually believes these things like it's
almost pointing out like the is there
something like that like he's pointing
out that I think he's pointing out the
white racism the racism I mean he's
point out the white reason that they
could believe these things about those
people right 100% he's doing it um but
also you know who knows no I don't know
what he feels I'll be honest I have to
look at every single one again I die
laughing I die laughing
a
it's no different than seeing like a fat
person fall it's [ __ ] hilarious you
listen to seeing like a dude eat a
[ __ ] hot dog and his friends laugh at
it like that's the type of humor to me
but he's not keeping that same energy
and it's kind of annoying when people
who aren't from here come here and they
trash half the [ __ ] country and they
have no clue about those people
whatsoever yeah and they're doing it to
serve themselves so it's like if you
here's my issue with it at the end of
the day is if you're you're not fighting
against racism you're profiting off of
racism just like white people are
profiting off of racism right you're
using racism to line your pockets and
you're not exposing that people are
racist to us [ __ ] we know we're
from here we know about white racism
you've just found out you got off the
boat to your points in a little bit to
your point I got more annoyed when he
started being more socially vocal this
year because before I just thought he it
was who do I make fun of I was an easy
target let's make fun of that that's an
easy target they almost make fun of that
because I also know like the Andy Rooney
interview he did when he was pretending
to be Ollie gee and he's interviewing
this [ __ ] elite newscaster and just
pissing him off with his misuse of
grammar and his stupid ask questions and
like I thought hey he just makes fun of
people that are targets how can I make
fun of this guy let's go yeah well when
he started getting more social I was
like whee nobody wants what was he's
doing socially what was he like he
recently said some [ __ ] like as Sacha
Baron Cohen not as a character not as a
joke like he went on like he had a very
long speech about I don't know I tuned
that [ __ ] out immediately but see like
the problems with American politics and
whatever how we approach did it I can't
recall exactly when Twitter viral to
mouth the other boys me about him is
that oftentimes the people that he's
exploiting and making fun of or like
typically nothing but like really kind
and welcoming to him like specifically
in Borah like he like goes into people's
homes that know that he's like a
foreigner that no he's from what country
he's from Kazakhstan yeah but still like
let him into their home and let him eat
dinner with them and like let him sing
the national anthem and then
intentionally tries to make them look
stupid yeah he's a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
but to me he feels like exploitative
like he's exploiting him he's really
sweet and he's profiting off of the
racism that he's a
using them up yeah like watch you if you
really want to fight racism and you're
trying to expose it give all your money
back give all the money you made off of
showing that people are racist give it
back
would you say he's fighting against it a
little bit by showing how dumb they are
I don't think he's fighting at all I
think what he's doing is cleverly
editing the video to show that these
people are racist but if you actually
look what Mark was saying is if you
actually pull out you'e wait a minute
they can't be hateful if they brought
him into their home they're feeding the
guy they're being sweet to him and a lot
of these people like even when he was
singing a song at the [ __ ] thing a
lot of these people are seeing an idiot
on stage and they feel bad for the idiot
so they're trying to make the idiot feel
better right are they raised or are they
trying to agree with someone that they
feel bad for he's like throw the Jew
down the world that song what was that
one where he goes to the rodeo and he's
singing a song like yeah thinking about
trying to kill the Jews to the American
can be free this is one of March so I
remember that yeah yeah
rodeo dress yeah that's point he's
singing the song going wild and all
people kind of like start seeing along
with them yeah and it's like maybe the
races but maybe like they're just trying
to go along with this guy from this
country that's a little that's a lot I
was like I'd be like yo keep the same
Andrea go to Israel and say like throw
the Palestine Palestinian down to well
right now you think you might get a
little support yeah but you're not gonna
do that video right or if you even were
like hey like if you would never do
anything that would expose the people
that are paying you like he would never
do anything that's gonna expose the the
the side of Showtime or the side of HBO
or side of whatever network is paying
him to do his shows I don't think you
would ever do anything to [ __ ] the bag
up so at the end of the day you're just
doing it for money bro yeah yeah I mean
which is fine but don't act like you're
like keeping the same energy don't act
like you do you taking advantage of
these people just like races take
advantage of these people you party the
same [ __ ] thing no if you want to
make fun of everybody less [ __ ] Gulf
the other wild thing about it is there's
one part of who is America what he's
interviewing like a high-ranking
politician or something like powerful
person in Vegas and he's making some
joke where's Nicole do you think you
could get me a going
and the guy was like well I can't but I
know someone that could what and he was
like wait what and he's like yeah like I
mean like the cameras are off right and
they weren't but he was like yeah I
could hook it up and basically was like
uncovering like this pedophile ring with
his powerful dude and he was like yeah I
didn't want to include it in the episode
because I felt like it was a [ __ ]
coward something I don't know the exact
details apparently after he gave the
interview would explained it people were
like well why didn't you say something
he was like oh I turned it over to the
FBI [ __ ] so you part of it he turned
it over that for yeah after Black Arts
because it on something you put that out
you'll know I protect these people now
hold the hold up you're in a
conversation with a stranger right you
make a joke yeah we might have to knock
this dude up we may he make we make a
joke right you're in a conversation
straight you make a little joke about
getting boys and he goes honestly if you
wanted a boy I could probably arrange
that I mean the cameras are off right
the next thing you do is you go to the
police and you get this guy arrested or
you get this guy locked up in some way
where you could find out where this
[ __ ] boy ring is and also I would lie
and be like yeah cameras are off and
then I would put it out online a medium
no certain apps are gonna do [ __ ] so hey
national TV let's do something now
[ __ ] a fraud
I've been he actually is talking about
how you can silence the boy really that
was his issues like yeah I'm Alyssa this
kid he's like talking what do I do and
the guy was like oh I can I get you a
lawyer to like silence the kid I got you
that's and he cut that part out of the
episode yeah and he talked about it
later and then there was some backlash
and then apparently released all the
information that I feel so come on now
yo come on bro you know what time it is
you know what's going on mmm that's wild
yeah why are you looking it up right now
so that's the thing like that's the
thing with these guys these like woke
[ __ ] is like you know exactly
did you come in here to get the [ __ ]
bag and this is what Americans do and I
don't know why we're so [ __ ] welcoming
and maybe we're it were not welcoming
maybe we're so divided that if you just
appease one side we don't care about the
other but like Americans aren't united
enough where we'd come here and go who
the [ __ ] is this foreign rich
[ __ ] coming here making fun of
us we go oh they're making fun of the
people
he's making fun of people that I don't
like or I'm told not to like hahaha
we're so loyal aside that if if one side
was like now having sex with kids is
okay people from that side would be like
yeah I guess so
like I really believe that but that
health look that like Americans on some
level I wish we would come together and
be like you know we're not gonna let
these foreigners come in here and judge
us like they know [ __ ] if you come in
you spent some time here and you
actually learn about the people you
gonna [ __ ] make fun of okay fine
but you're not gonna just hop off and
then just type you know and yeah all
these [ __ ] like you don't go
hop off the [ __ ] plane and then
appease one side by [ __ ] all over
the other side is forever no is you
always speak on racism in America and
this is how you want to effect change
cool there's a lot of racism south
apartheid done this [ __ ] legit ended
after the Simpsons The Simpsons is older
than black people being free and in
South Africa so it's like if you so
that's where it's like and we have to
understand is is a comedic show and it
has to be a comedic show with the first
purpose comedy because if the first
purpose was any racism you know where
you would start right you star in the
place where your family's members are
enduring that [ __ ] all the time right
right but if your first purpose is being
like a really famous and wealthy comic
then you're here yes and that's how i'ma
treat you as someone who just want to
make a lot of money yes and but I'm not
gonna take you seriously politically
because if you really want to help you
gonna go you wanna start way at home and
this is the most fertile market for
conscious comedy that's how progressive
America is you can make the most money
here being progressive and fighting
racism South Africa you gonna make as
much over there because the white people
their product yeah yeah it's it is it is
something rubs me the wrong way man
something especially with with the sacha
parent baron-cohen dude like it's always
I've laughed my [ __ ] ass off I was
laughing today when I was watching a
clip but there was always something
about it that maybe it was what you said
mark it was just exploitive and it
seemed like it was just exploiting
people who kinda were being nice and
taking someone in see I didn't see it as
social because I was like oh he's being
straight mean to some of these people
were led them into his house but it is
still funny so funny is funny and I
laugh I hadn't I didn't see it as like
trying to push any social agenda
recently he started being more social
and even then I
kind of disassociated the two like he's
being social now yeah right yeah a phase
point is I want to expose these
underbellies of America's like nah yeah
and you can look at it just being funny
and kind of see it almost like jackass
then great that's how in the way he
opens Borat with the [ __ ] chicken and
then he starts unpacking in the elevator
room he's like I won't go to a small and
the elevators like I won't go to a
smaller hotel room yeah it's like it's
all just to me primarily funny yeah we
went to try to make some sort of greater
deduction about like American society
through it seems it yeah shut your mouth
if he's doing that that's usually boiled
little rich boy from Oxford shut the
[ __ ] up how dare you come here make fun
of us eventually Americans we're gonna
have enough pride together where we're
like yo who the [ __ ] do you think you
are
[Applause]